what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to the room around of our
weekly series where we keep you guys
updated on all the news and rumors that
you may have missed over the course of
the week even though we were lazy and
didn't do it last week so we're opening
this episode up with something that's
not really the most important thing ever
in the history of the world but is kind
of cool at least in comparison to what
we're gonna be talking about later on in
the episode because wanda might be
meeting the x-men
god i'm so hyped we are opening this up
with the fact that spider-man no way
home the trailer for that movie has
actually outperformed avengers in-game
now that doesn't really surprise me to
be honest with you guys it doesn't
really shock me and the reason why is
because
the anticipation for avengers game had
kind of been going for like 10 years
right going all the way back to the
first avengers movie if we really want
to be specific about it loki had an
infinity stone we saw thanos in a
post-credits scene so we were kind of
like okay so like putting two and two
together we're gonna end up getting like
the infinity gauntlet and shortly after
that like all the pieces started to fall
into place so in reality we knew that
was coming with spider-man no way home
it's been nothing but rumors right like
nothing had been confirmed and even then
the hype for the movie had just kind of
taken on a life of its own i mean you
guys you guys know the feeling right i
mean you guys remember this feeling i
mean you guys had it like three days ago
this feeling was this idea that like
something big was gonna happen in
spider-man no way home because a lot of
big things have happened that are going
to affect spider-man no way home and a
lot of big things have happened since
the end of avengers end game see running
up to avengers in game there were some
cool things that happened but nothing
monumental or landmark it was a bunch of
individual character story arcs that's
really all it was the formation of the
avengers the coming of ultron different
things like that and it was kind of cool
but since the ending of avengers in-game
the big question that we've always had
is what comes next it's the events of
wand division right wanda altering
reality becoming the scarlet witch and
then going out into the multiverse right
you guys remember the one division show
we were just we were all on pins and
needles and everybody wanted to see
mephisto but it left us with this idea
of holy crap something big is coming and
then you go into loki and then the
multiverse comes back after we meet
immortus and so all these things kind of
coalesced in such a short amount of time
that by the time we realized that
spider-man no way home was going to tie
into some multiversal shenanigans and
then couple that with the rumors that
toby mcguire and andrew garfield were
going to appear in the film well hell is
no wonder the trailer outperformed
avengers in game
i would argue spider-man no way home is
the single most anticipated trailer
that's been released by marvel to date
because it's just the one thing people
want to know about people wanted to see
what was going to be going on in the
movie or at least have some indication
of what was happening so it doesn't
surprise me the trailer did that well
but it is cool to know that it did but
going into our second bit of news here
the photo leaks for andrew garfield
spider-man and spider-man no way home
have been scrubbed seemingly from the
internet by sony now this can only mean
one of two things right it means the
rumors are true the rumors are false
good job rob way to be an absolute
genius here
what i mean by that is that in this day
and age it's very easy for inaccurate
information to be seminated out there
right to kind of get out there into the
world and paint an incorrect picture so
this could very well just be sony doing
damage control right just be like no no
no andrew garfield's not going to be in
this movie we don't want people you know
circulating around photos that indicate
that he is but the other part of this is
that coming off the heels of the trailer
he is going to be there right because
i'm sure all of you guys saw that leaked
trailer i mean sony tried to take that
down with a quickness right when that
spider-man trailer leaked on tick-tock
dude it was like that there were entire
accounts that were just being shut down
just just done right i mean at that
point it's on the internet there's no
way to remove it in its entirety but
based on what we saw with that super
grainy low quality trailer it was
legitimately the trailer that we
eventually saw without all the visual
effects so it's entirely possible that
this these kind of set clips or these
set photos of andrew garfield on
spider-man that he is actually going to
be in it and it's sony just rushing to
get that stuff taken down as fast as
they can which would really only do what
we expected to do which is confirm that
andrew garfield is really going to be in
spider-man 3. now i don't know if that's
true or not i don't know if if andrew
garfield is going to be in spider-man no
way home there's no way to know until we
basically end up seeing him in the
trailer or if he's just like on the set
in a spider-man costume taking a selfie
alongside toby mcguire and tom holland i
doubt that disney or sony or marvel
studios would let that happen
but it'd be amazing if it did
[Laughter]
it would be awesome if it did dude that
would that would probably perform better
than the ellen degeneres selfie that
crashed twitter you guys remember that
when ellen degeneres did that it was the
craziest thing ever but nonetheless
right this seems to possibly confirm
that andrew garfield is indeed going to
be in the new spider-man film so not
overly important here but it is kind of
a cool little thing and getting into our
third little tidbit here again this is a
pretty kind of a scant episode right
except for our final topic which is cool
uh venom 2 is not delayed those you guys
who don't know what's going on with this
rumors have been going around that venom
2 has been delayed and it wasn't delayed
now it is delayed and there's been a lot
of speculation as to why a lot of people
are saying that because of what's going
on in spider-man no way home tom hardy
may or may not have a role in that movie
so they're laying the film to make sure
that what goes on is spider-man 2
segway's end of venom 2 so the movie
actually makes sense when you see it
there's a lot of people out there which
i believe sony's part of that crowd and
saying that's not the case there is
belief out there that the the kovid 19
delta variant it's what's leading to the
movie being postponed in the hopes that
more people will be vaccinated more
people will go see it in the theaters
that kind of a thing there's a lot of
speculation going on here regarding why
the movie was potentially delayed but
sony ultimately came out and said no
it's not right it only came out 19 hours
ago and said nope the movie is not
delayed it's going to come out on its
scheduled time which is great right i
was a huge fan of the first venom movie
i absolutely loved it and i'm really
excited to see what they do with the
second one because carnage looks amazing
but to put this to bed the movie will
come out on time now to the meat and
potatoes in this video and probably the
only reason any of you guys click on it
which is the single most important thing
rumors are abound that scarlet witch
wanda is gonna face off against somebody
from the fox x-men universe now not
specifically the x-men universe the fox
verse what's the difference remember fox
owned the fantastic four movie rights so
honestly we really didn't see anything
from the fantastic four since that
terrible fanfic movie it's okay michael
b jordan you're an amazing actor we give
you a pass
everybody else you are bad so here's the
thing about the the fantastic four film
or at least wanda and the fantastic four
this presents a lot of possibilities
right we don't know what role wanda is
going to be playing in doctor strange
too but presumably she's going to be
moving her way making her way around the
multiverse probably trying to find her
kids wherever her kids happen to be
there's a lot of possibilities on who
she could be facing off against because
there's a lot of magical beings out
there with a lot of power now if you
guys are interested we can make a video
on some of these really really powerful
beings and who our picks are for who
wanda would face off against but to give
you guys a little indication of what
could possibly happen here there's
characters like doctor doom there's
ileana rasputin also known as magic of
course magneto would probably be the fan
choice for her to fight because the
whole thing with them and and him being
her dad has kind of been off and on
right if you go when you read vision and
scarlet witch vol 1 that the whole story
that little mini series focuses around
the idea that wanda is the daughter of
magneto but then you go forward from
marvel probably about four or five
decades and you end up finding out that
her and quicksilver are not the children
of magneto so that's kind of been off
and on off and on off and on and marvel
has changed that a lot over the years
the important thing here is that the
relationship between magneto and scarlet
witch is one that people would like to
see even if he's not necessarily the
biological father of wanda because
that's something to keep in mind here
right it'd be very easy for the mcu to
come back at some previous point in time
or some future point in time and say the
parents that wanda thought were her
biological parents that's not true that
they're not it right that she actually
had biological parents eric lyncher and
most likely magda who was her biological
mother in the comics and that ultimately
they ended up having to leave for
whatever reason either because magneto
became a villain after his wife died i
don't know any number of reasons right i
mean technically his he lost his mind
after his first kid died his wife was
pregnant with vision and scarlet witch
and then she took off when he killed
like an entire village of people out of
revenge and then she ended up having
quick silver and scarlet witch later on
and magneto just didn't know about it
for years and years and years but it's
entirely possible they could do that
right come back at a future point in
time and say actually wanda and
quicksilver's parents are not the people
that you saw in one division it's
actually these guys over here one of
whom is magneto that's possible i don't
know if they'll necessarily do that but
people want to see that relationship in
the movies right they want to see even
if he's not necessarily her father the
two of them meet and encounter each
other plus it'd make for a pretty
interesting battle i mean truth to tell
if we're really being honest with
ourselves given the level of power that
wanda has in the mcu the fact that she's
a multiversal force the only person that
could probably stand against her would
be jean grey with the phoenix right
magneto would get absolutely crushed
even somebody like thanos with the
infinity gauntlet would get wrecked by
by wanda because she's now multiversal
level right she's not a universal power
anymore she's a multiversal power now
which means she transcends the power of
an infinity gauntlet which is kind of
bonkers when you think about it but it'd
be a cool thing to see right having her
face off against jean grey with the
power of a phoenix and just that absurd
level of magical energy being emanated
around there's a lot of possible options
there the important thing and the real
big takeaway from this is this looks
like if it's true the first beginnings
of when we'll start seeing what used to
be fox properties that are now owned by
disney coming into the marvel cinematic
universe now whether or not they'll be
mainstays in the sense that we'll see
her fight like like silver surfer or
galactus or something like that and then
like we get to the end of the movie and
this galactus will return and fantastic
four we don't know if we'll really get
anything like that i mean i presume we
will i don't know why we wouldn't and
they might just kind of be using it as a
bit of a test bed just to kind of see
how people respond to these things or it
could very well just be like a
five-minute moment and that's it right
like we pick up with wanda as she's
fighting somebody from the fox first and
the fight's over like five minutes after
we begin that scene and then you move on
to whatever the next thing is right as
she's passing through that universe we
don't necessarily know i mean honestly
if if it's not jean grey my pick would
be professor x just because the
relationship between the two during the
events of house of m right for those of
you guys who don't know what that is
during house of m when wanda had
basically warped and rewrote all of
reality the way she was able to do that
was one because of the power she had but
two because she kidnapped professor x
and then took over his powers to read
the subconscious thoughts of everybody
on earth and then rewrite reality to
give them what they essentially had
always wanted even if they didn't
necessarily know that's what they
actually wanted that's where the whole
house of m universe came from but that
kind of relationship right there could
be pretty important it'd be pretty cool
especially if what they're doing is
building the groundwork for house of m
later on down the line and we'll talk
more about that potential when we do
this video on who wanda could be
fighting from the fox universe assuming
you guys are interested in it again let
us know down in the comment section if
you guys want to see something like that
but again this is a pretty short episode
guys not a whole ton of news and rumors
out there honestly so much has been
going on in the aftermath of the
spider-man trailer there's not really a
whole lot there i mean there is stuff
like shane she said he wants to work
with the guardians of the galaxy but i
mean who cares about that in comparison
to like the spider-man trailer rumors
right i mean nobody cares right at least
not right now anyway give it like two
weeks everybody's gonna start carrying
again especially when we get closer to
the release of the film but the
important thing here is that it's not
the most packed episode there ever was
but it really is all just kind of focus
on the aftermath of the spider-man
trailer so with that being said guys let
us know down in the comments who you
want to see wanda face off against in
the mcu from the fox properties and we
will catch you all later
peace